hey everyone Sal here and I wanted to
show you an in-depth demo of the new AI
that we have happening throughout Khan
Academy and what you're going to see is
that it exists in two ways one is
helping students and Learners and
teachers with many of the things that
people already familiar with Khan
Academy and as we'll see also
introducing a whole new series of
activities that you can now do with the
artificial intelligence
so what I see here what we see here is a
classic Khan Academy exercise but you
notice there's this little bot here so
we could click on that I'm here to help
you with this exercise here are a few
ideas or things that you can ask me and
you could ask any of those things but I
think what's really interesting is its
ability to be a thoughtful tutor so if I
just say tell me
tell me the answer
exclamation mark I'm very entitled here
oh I see you're eager to find the answer
but remember I'm here to help you learn
how to solve it on your own let's start
by looking at the equation what do you
think the first step should be so notice
it's really doing what you would expect
a good tutor to be and let me actually
do a mistake here so let's do three
minus this is a common mistake when
Distributing only multiplying it times
the first term minus 18 plus 2m is equal
to m
it says oops it looks like there's a
small mistake when you distributed
the negative 2 inside the parentheses I
put an upside down smiley face make sure
you distribute the negative 2 to both
terms in the parentheses the correct
distribution would be this try again let
me know
if you need help you got this and then
if I were to write 3 minus 18 minus 4M
is equal to m
great job you distributed the negative 2
correctly this time now you have the
following what do you think the next
step should be to solve for M so as you
can tell this is really doing what we
think a really thoughtful tutor would do
and this doesn't just work in math this
works across all subjects that Khan
Academy has now it's not just exercises
this is going to sound like an
infomercial I'm going to keep saying and
there's more you could do with this with
videos this is just a classic Khan
Academy video that
hopefully many of y'all are familiar
with you can do fun things like write a
poem about this video and so notice in
both the previous example where it uh it
where I got help with the problem it
already had the context of the problem
it knows what I'm already doing on Khan
Academy likewise here it already knows
about the video it's able to understand
what's actually in the contents of the
video it wrote a very nice poem here in
the land of math where equations play a
problem arose one sunny day negative
nine minus 9x minus six a challenge to
solve a puzzle to fix on the other hand
that's actually as you can see here
that's actually the actual problem that
is in this video on the other side 3
times 4X plus 6 we must simplify with
our math tricks distribute we must and
combine like terms too to find the value
of x that's what we will do
and it keeps going on so that's fun but
there's other things you could do you
could say
why do I need to learn this
and it asks what are your interests or
goals knowing that will help me explain
how this math concept might be relevant
to you
say I
really love
I don't know soccer
see what it says great in soccer math
can be quite useful
especially when analyzing player
performance game statistics and team
strategies understanding equations like
the one in the video can help you grasp
more advanced math concepts which can be
applied to soccer analytics predicting
player movements and even optimizing
training routines so learning this is
this math concept can enhance your
understanding and appreciation of the
beautiful game and gotta love the Emojis
is doing here so this is once again
across all the videos all the Articles
all the exercises on Khan Academy you
can either you can even do things like
this quiz me
and obviously Khan Academy already has a
lot of exercises but here we can just do
more and this is directly related to uh
what's going on in the video
but now you know we've just shown how
the AI can be helpful with things that
people are already used to doing on Khan
Academy I'll now show how it can be
useful for introducing a whole new
series of activities that uh some of
which I think would have looked like
science fiction even a few months ago so
I'm logged in right now as a teacher and
you can see a couple of interesting
things here you can see activities for
teachers and you can also see activities
for Learners and we already have a bunch
and we're going to be adding more in the
weeks and months to come but one really
interesting thing and this is an
important safety is you see it says this
conversation is recorded and viewable by
your teacher and we're doing that and if
there's a parent attached to this
account it'll say recorded and viewable
by your teacher and your parent or or
your parent and the whole point of that
is we know that the that artificial
intelligence large language models has a
lot of power and it can be a really
powerful learning tool as I'm about to
show you but we also want to make sure
that there's proper guard rails we've
put a lot of guard rails into the actual
tool we're also being very careful where
we're not passing any personally
identifiable information to the actual
artificial intelligence we are also not
using student data to train it so
parents teachers students can rest
assured that this is as safe of an
environment as we can create we're also
putting guard rails around the
activities so that students can only use
it to learn and not use it to to cheat
but uh before so as I said parents and
teachers can see everything that
students are up to and if students try
to do something that's a little bit off
might be harmful to themselves or others
parents and teachers will be notified
but just to get a sense of the types of
activities we can engage in you have
this tutor me activity which is actually
very similar to what we did in that
exercise but here you can get tutored on
pretty much any any subject you want in
math or science or the humanities
uh we could say I want to understand
entropy
more
ah entropy a fascinating Concept in B
indeed to better understand your current
knowledge can you tell me what you
already know about entropy or what
specific aspect you'd like to explore so
we can continue to have a conversation
and it acts like a really good tutor uh
this is a fun one called ignite your
curiosity we could pick from one of
these subjects here or you can even put
another approach as long as it's
appropriate it won't let you go to any
inappropriate uh topics hopefully
um but let's say you say I want to
explore I want to explore world history
and this is
a kind of a way of jumping into the
rabbit hole where it gives you some
interesting questions but you can ask
your own questions at any time as well
but says Ah world history a tapestry of
tales woven together through time and I
love the Emojis let's dive into some
tantalizing questions and so we can pick
or we could ask our own what was the
real purpose behind the construction of
the Great Wall of China how did the Silk
Road impact the world
etc etc I I don't know I'm kind of
curious about that first one the real
purpose of the construction of the Great
Wall of China
ah the Great Wall of China a magnificent
Marvel stretching over 13 000 miles the
primary purpose of the Great Wall was to
protect China from Invasion by nomadic
times particularly the Mongols it also
helped as a symbol of power and unity
showcasing the strength of the Chinese
Empire so we can keep asking more
questions I could also say why couldn't
the Mongols
just go over or around the wall
we put the wall in capital
uh excellent question while the Great
Wall was an imposing structure it wasn't
entirely impenetrable in fact the
Mongols did manage to breach the wall on
several occasions however the wall still
served a significant deterrent and made
envisions more and more difficult so
this is just a fun way to really dive
deep and I gotta say again I love I love
the Emojis now beyond that we have
practice in pretty much any subject that
a student might want let's say we wanted
to prepare for a trivia night but you
could really put almost anything here
that's reasonable
and so it asked you questions in which
country would you find the Great Pyramid
of Giza of course of course going to be
Egypt and so great it matches what's the
largest planet of solar system you could
keep going but it also maybe more
importantly has many many different
academic subjects in elementary school
middle school I could go through each of
these both Humanities and stem subjects
middle school high school we have every
AP course here for example I could click
on I don't know let's click on US
government
awesome Choice here are 10 top 10
subtopics in AP US Government that you
might want to be quizzed on so what do
we want to do we could do all of the
above I don't know let's do foundations
of American democracy
and once again it is doing quizzing it's
going to quiz me as much as I want and
help evaluate me but I can also ask
questions about whenever I want
so the first question what are the key
principles of John Locke's political
philosophy that influenced the founding
fathers when drafting the US
Constitution don't worry if you're not
sure I can always give hints or explain
things so let's say give me a hint
so it's centered around the idea of
natural rights and social contract think
about three fundamental rights you
believed all individuals had and how the
government's role is to protect these
rights so let's say the right
to
the right to property
and to be happy
I'm intentionally not giving it the
perfect answer
so it says so it gives its take you know
you are on the right track with the
right to property and happiness the key
principles are life liberty and property
which are similar to the phrase life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
found in the Declaration of Independence
great effort and you could keep going
what is the main purpose of the
Federalists to argue for a stronger
Central
government
than what we're in the article well I'll
just write it that way
you got it right the Federalist Papers
were indeed written to argue for a
stronger central government so you can
quiz yourself as much as you want on any
of these topics I think this will be
particularly uh useful honestly for any
student who's looking to study across
subjects stem and Humanities especially
a lot of students preparing for AP going
well into college and Beyond and if you
don't see something that you have here
if you're taking more specialized course
you could just type it in over here we
have these activities where students can
debate the AI or debate conmigor or vice
versa these are Elementary School topics
like are zoos helpful or harmful to
animals you have Middle School topics
like are cell phones helpful or harmful
in classrooms high school and Beyond
topics and we've populated a bunch of
them like should the student government
cancel student debt well artificial
intelligence help or hurt the job market
what you can do is you can take one side
of the issue so let's say let's debate
whether the government should cancel
student debt and I'm just this is you
know don't don't send me mail I'm just
taking one point of view to fine-tune
the arguments on either side I will not
tell you my actual opinion but let's say
I'm against
I'm against canceling
the debt
all right you're against canceling
student debt please go ahead and present
your argument and I'll be ready to
counter and present my side let the
debate begin
and so we can say
canceling
doesn't
solve the underlying
issue of expensive
College
you cancel
for one group and
and the next generation will still
accumulate
debt let's see what else could I say oh
I could I could say
this is also
an insult
to those who worked
hard to pay their
debt and is a
a dis incentive
for others to pay
hoping it will be canceled
the real
solution is to make College cheaper
and let's see what it responds ah well
constructed argument I see your point
about canceling student debt not
addressing the root cause of expensive
college education and I understand how
it might seem unfair to those who have
already paid off their debts however
allow me to present the other side of
the coin canceling student debt even if
it doesn't solve the owner and you could
see it keeps going on and on you can
spend hours with this thing and this is
just one of the many many many things
you can debate we can chat with a
historical figure for example let's talk
to
I don't know let's talk to
[Music]
um
let me talk to
let me talk to George Washington
uh it is an honor to be summoned as the
first president United States George
Washington I am here to share my
experiences and answer your questions as
long as they pertain to my time and
context what inquiry do you have for me
my dear fellow and do tell me what
interests you most about my life or the
era in which I lived have you ever been
unsure of
yourself
indeed there were moments in my life
when I experienced uncertainty and doubt
leading the Continental Army during the
American Revolution was a great
responsibility and I often found myself
questioning my decisions however I
firmly believed it was the cause for it
was I firmly believed in the cause for
which we fought and I endeavored to
learn from my mistakes and adopt my
strategies accordingly so obviously we
could go on and ask all sorts of things
and of course this is a simulation it's
you know
to treat it as it is but there's a lot
that we can we can be doing here
literary characters uh there are some
here I could say well you know I like
unless I would love to meet Zeus
ah mortal I am Zeus the king of the Gods
and ruler of Mount Olympus I preside
over the sky and thunder and uphold
Justice and law what does thou wish to
know or discuss with me the Mighty Zeus
and what questions
what are your insecurities
I've always wanted to know this uh as
Zeus the supreme ruler of the Gods I am
not one to dwell on insecurities however
I faced many challenges in maintaining
my rule and ensuring the Loyalty of my
fellow gods and goddesses there have
been times when my authority has been
questioned and I've had to assert my
power to maintain order now mortal tell
me about a challenge you have faced in
your life and how you overcame it so
it's nicely driving the conversation but
there is more this is essentially a
college coach that you could talk to
about navigating financial aid how you
can pick Majors etc etc also a lot of
fun this is a fun activity that helps
combine reading comprehension and
vocabulary
and get a little fact knowledge there so
it says you know let me know what grade
level you're in I don't know let me say
I'm sixth grader
it's going to give me 10 vocabulary
words it would be useful for a sixth
grader to know
and then it's going to use them it's
going to construct passages and we I can
pick what I want the story to be around
so let's say let's make it about
um
the Mysterious Island a journey through
space and time
all right so what it's doing now is it's
using those vocabulary words one
paragraph at a time and I need to
identify which of those usages were was
incorrect so once upon a time a group of
apprehensive explorers set sail on a
daring adventure to find well
apprehensive doesn't sound right that's
not what an Explorer would be so I'll
write apprehensive
is wrong
should be something like Brave
or Intrepid
whoops
you got it apprehensive doesn't fit the
context and braver Intrepid would be a
better choice great job and so and then
it keeps building on that story about
the explorers and it's actually giving
me some content knowledge while we're
doing it this craft a story it's
essentially it helps develop characters
and then it trades off it's an activity
that many of y'all might have seen maybe
you've done it with kids or you've done
it with your parents where you write a
paragraph then it writes a paragraph
then you write a paragraph then it
writes a paragraph and you work with the
bot to create a story and we really you
know this is really important to us that
we're all about learning and not about
cheating so this isn't about hey just do
the essay for me it's about let's do
something creative together
now I promised that it wouldn't just be
for students it's also for teachers they
can develop parts of a lesson like a
lesson hook or exit tickets or entire
lesson plans altogether so ask me what
grade I'm teaching let's say I'm
teaching ninth grade
I want to teach I'm going to teach the
causes of the Civil
of the civil War
oh the cause of the Civil War what a
fascinating thought-provoking topic for
ninth graders anyway would you like me
to create a rough draft of the lesson
plan or do you want to provide more
information to customize it further so
you can and you could say whether you
want to be Project based or Hands-On or
whether you want to facilitate a
conversation they'll go into all of the
details of what makes a great lesson
plan but just for the sake of this demo
I'm just going to say give me a rough
draft just see what it what it can
produce on this
and what's interesting is it is
producing a full complete lesson plan
that I can take with 9th graders that
would be appropriate for them and it it
it produces it and I can then tweak it
if I want them to make it more exciting
or make it more Hands-On or change the
assessment
um or or I could I could answer more of
its questions however however wants and
you know it's just fun to see like you
know even like some of the hooks and
things it creates begin with a quick
pull do you think the Civil War was a
was inevitable why or why not and
encourage students to share their
thoughts briefly and you could ask for a
different type of hook and we even have
a lesson hook
um actual activity here this refreshed
my knowledge is
forced a teacher uh if hey you know I
teach the Civil War every year but right
before I teach it it's nice to be able
to at least make sure that I have I have
a decent handle or I remember all of the
details so let's say I had that lesson
ninth grade
ninth grade causes of the Civil
War
so quizzing on the topic learning
through conversation let's say I'm quiz
quiz me on the topic
so here's like the major
the major things first concept economic
and social difference between the North
South can you explain the key
differences between the North and South
that contributed to tensions North
was more Industrial
and
didn't
have slavery
South
was agricultural
and was dependent
on slavery
to some degree
that's correct so this is a way I as a
teacher can just make sure that okay and
this works not just in the humanities
you could it could be in the Sciences
whatever you're about to teach you can
get the lesson plan get your hook
refresh your knowledge
um and then there's even a couple of fun
things here you can kind of just put
stuff about your classroom here and it
can kind of create a fun poem for what
everyone did together and as much as you
already see here and I haven't even gone
through all of all of these activities
and I obviously haven't shown you all
the other stuff on Khan Academy and the
related links and how it can connect
what you're doing here to the other
things on Khan Academy
we hope to we're already testing this
with teachers and co-designing it with
teachers and Educators working with
students
um and this is all right now going to be
behind con Labs we're creating a waiting
list for any of y'all who want to be
part of it we are going to prioritize
donors because we do need to fund the
research and development of this but
over the coming months we hope to roll
this out to more and more folks with a
priority for schools in the uh that are
already part of the Khan Academy
District offering and we also hope to
release more and more activities for
teachers parents and students
hopefully on even a weekly basis
um in the in the months to come so uh I
look forward to for all of you all
getting a chance to uh to Play and Learn
with conmigo